hope this is working I hope this is
working is it
working is this working is this working
okay we'll see let's see I got to oh
okay hi yay I think it's working I think
it's
working hooray hi guys happy Friday okay
don't mind me I'm just going to social
media that this is finally goddamn
working um hold on a second I'm so
excited that you guys are here and
you've dealt with um My Endless
inability to do things that are
seemingly easy so how do I see how this
is on my channel can I see this on my
what what what how do I
okay oh I can add oh my God I can filter
this what I can f oh my God I can filter
this live stream you guys this is a
Brave New World hold on
whoa this is a flashback and now we're
back in real time except it's a little
hazy of a memory uh oh my gosh I had no
idea you could filter this like this
this is called the glamour filter I
don't think this is very glamorous this
is like a
porn um I kind of like this one you guys
like this one
I okay cool um how do I how do I how do
I how do I how do
I sorry guys I'm
just getting it together hold on um I'm
social mediating this
now I'm going to say oh crap
crra sorry this just sounds like I'm a
cave woman making grunting noises at you
um
now I'm just talking through my tweet
don't worry come hang
out or
don't okay just make sure
post okay hey
yay wow this is so exciting hi everyone
um so
this is cool I sorry the complication in
the delay of the live stream was that I
thought I could do it on my laptop and I
need like an encoder to do it and there
was a lot of things that I do not know
how to do that they were asking for me
to do and then I texted the always
reliable Hannah Hart and asked her what
she did and she said it was through your
phone so um so now we're here we're here
now we did it um which I'm I'm happy
better
late than pregnant you know that that's
my favorite phras um hi guys happy
Friday it is the rainiest of rainy days
in Los Angeles today and I had to shoot
this morning and was going to come back
and make a video for you guys for today
but I just didn't feel motivated to make
a video so I've been wanting to do a
live stream with all of you guys and so
this seemed like the most appropriate
time to do it so thanks um if any of you
are cu ious we got a sleepy Goose
happening right there uh that's how you
know it's a very rainy Friday in Los
Angeles oh and there's my cement fire
hydrant um this is how I know goose is
really smart is that she's never once
mistaken this for a real fire hydrant
and has never ever my lights are
flickering has never ever urinated on it
um this is the other reason that I'm
trying to like stay home right now is
that my lights have have been flickering
um on and off for the last like hour
hour and a half so I didn't want to
leave Goose by herself if the power went
out um I want her to see
firsthand how incapable I am of dealing
with the situation if the power goes out
um so that's what I've been up to what
have you guys been up to uh how was your
Friday going let's I'm this is so fun I
always talk myself out of doing live
streams cuz I get really nervous about
them and then I realize that they're
easy and fun and so this is something I
want to do more regularly I just need
you guys to kind of hold me accountable
if you don't mind um I'm like that
friend that says I give up I'm giving up
sugar and then like we'll try and eat
just like a pound of Snickers in front
of you so hold me accountable to doing
live streams in the future if that's
what you guys are also interested in
also don't hold me accountable if you
don't want to see live streams that's
how easy it works
um let's
see these comments are going really fast
this is testing my eyeballs notification
Squad yeah all right cool notification
Squad uh I love live stream someone said
their car died I'm so sorry about that
rest in peace car um hopefully it's gone
on to a better car life how was that
midnight live speaking of live yeah last
night if you guys didn't see Hannah mry
and I we did at midnight live which is
the Comedy Central game show hosted
Chris Hardwick and that show is pretty
stressful I will say when it's taped you
have to come up with a lot of jokes for
a lot of things and it's super fun it's
always super super fun and it's always
super educational about what's happening
on the internet um for me but it is a
lot of work and this time around it was
live which um added a whole new level
but thankfully Hanah and M were the
other people on the show with me so
we're all really comfortable and it was
really fun and you can watch it I think
on demand now if you missed it last
night so that's that's it I love that
hoodie someone said this hoodie was
given to me by Twitter when Hannah May
and I were doing our press tour for
dirty30 and watch this oh that's my
Twitter handle can you believe it can
you believe it so when I want to go
Incognito in public I always wear this
hoodie so no one
knows the drawstring is uneven that's
correct cuz this one is down and this
one is up does that bother people I'll
fix it I know that this is a thing that
bothers people from time to time so hold
on would you rather the drawstrings be
even with a tiny scrunched Hood in the
back would you rather the hood be
totally
like normal but this isn't I'll fix it
I'm sorry guys I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I know this is okay hold on we're
going to fix it so everyone feels
comfortable is that is that okay look is
that okay for everyone is that okay this
is okay right all right
you guys tell me if it's still a
problem
okay just making sure that everyone's
like please fix it please fix it please
fix it I'm I feel for you I feel for you
okay um thoughts on the weather um the
it's it's real gross out right now it's
really disgusting and
um everyone in Los Angeles as you know
stereotype doesn't drive Well normally
and so when it rains people extra don't
drive well and so it's not necessarily
me not wanting to drive but it's me not
wanting to be around people that don't
know how to drive in the rain which is
super fun he hey someone said ass and
all caps I feel you
so uh can I speed read I mean I
can I I can get through letters and
sounds on a you know
mediocre Pace poop okay global warming
okay these are all really interesting
comments really glad that I live stream
you guys I'm glad that you guys all have
a space to voice any of your thoughts
about things thoughts on pasta it is
good it's a dangerous dangerous food um
it is uh it's it's very
tantalizing it's very flirtatious but it
always kind of hurts kind of hurts
do you speak any other languages I do
not speak any other languages I took six
years of Latin five years of Latin in
middle school and high school um which
has done me wonders truly I can say
simper Ubbi subi which means always wear
underwear
so put five years into
something you come out with a something
uh I wish I spoke another language I
wish I spoke French I love French I took
French one also in high school I know I
can
say that means I don't speak um French I
speak English I think so there's that um
are you live streaming cuz you oh these
comments go so fast I can't read
them mamor bangs
yeah if you guys haven't acknowledge M
heart has bangs and they look real good
so um I think you should check them out
what's your least favorite language my
least favorite language not least
favorite but I think maybe Swedish only
because I have been conditioned as a
child um my only like Outlet to Swedish
culture was the Swedish Chef uh on the
Muppets and that was a parody of like
Swedish people um
so when I hear real Swedish conversation
happening I laugh laugh at it because
I've been conditioned via the Muppets to
laugh at Swedish conversation so it's
not my fault it's
Society um thoughts on Hamilton the
musical I haven't seen it but I very
very much love the soundtrack and I hope
to see it soon Hannah's song Hannah
posted a song Yesterday um that's an
original song that she was telling at
midnight that she wrote when she was 22
I haven't watched it yet but I have to I
definitely definitely have to um which I
what do you guys think of Hannah song I
heard it's awesome thoughts on pancakes
pancakes are like
um I mean they're just breakfast cake
it's just an excuse to eat breakfast
cake which is oh I'm your someone said
I'm your favorite Muppet thank you so
much thank you that is so kind of you I
can't believe leave it um oh you like
the short hair cool I like it too I it
it it makes me um more prone to
showering because doing my hair is much
easier whereas the extensions took a
really long time to fix after showers so
I would uh avoid showers mostly because
of my hair which would lead to a lot of
other complications in terms of just
body odor in general like hygiene so I
think it's a good this is good this is
good for me and for everyone that's um
in my physical proximity more Goose
please okay here's
Goose she's so
sleepy she's so tired cuz she cannot go
outside and urinate
so you can't hear but she's snoring she
snores a
lot cuz her snout is scrunched up so
she's truly not bred for breathing but
yeah know she's doing her best like we
all are um I think you're really funny I
love your videos thank you so much
that's so kind of you I really
appreciate it uh what color hair would I
want to try um well I've done brunette
oh Brown is my natural hair color like
this is my natural hair color um I maybe
I've always wanted to try red but I
always wanted like now that I see people
doing pink hair I think pink could be
cool I tried silver um which was really
cool but it just it washes out
extraordinarily quickly so um
that's something that it's a fleeting
feeling when you dye your hair one of
those colors um but I think pink would
be cool it'd be like I have cotton candy
on my head at all times so if I get
drunk enough and my hair gets stuck in
my mouth you know maybe I might be able
to convince myself that it's actually
just cotton candy how fun your teeth are
so white H girl or boy there is a
hardcore filter on this live stream so
thank you but they're not this White in
real life um the feed is going so fast I
know I didn't I don't know how to make
it not go fast someone said tits so you
know I see certain messages that come
through uh do I believe in the Loch Ness
monster
um no do I believe that someone might
have seen like a giant eel an ex you
know unexpectedly huge eel in a body of
water at some point
sure um but The Lochness Monster no but
I also like I don't totally rule out any
of those things like Bigfoot or any of
that's kind of like I don't know even
what you call it um because you I just I
don't know how I can't prove I can't
disprove it so why should I speak out
against it oh good someone said dick
that's excellent Reddit question mark
I've heard of that website what about
ghosts yeah I do believe I think I have
a ghost in my bathroom I have one light
in my bathroom there's like a bunch of
like recess lights like see how this
this is like a recess light it's like in
my ceiling so I have a bunch of recess
lights in my bathroom and there's just
one that flickers on and off but like
it'll I'll be in there doing my makeup
and 15 minutes into me doing my makeup
it'll just turn off while all the other
lights are on and then 10 minutes later
it'll turn back on um and I've taken the
light bulb out it's not the light bulb
I've put the light bulb back in I've
changed light bulbs from other recess
lights so I think it's a ghost um but I
think that they're just
like I think they're commenting on the
music that shuffles onto my Sonos cuz I
think when I have a speaker in my
bathroom too and so when a song comes on
that they don't like I think they just
turn off which hey I I relate to that
thoughts on the Netherlands cool I've
heard it's a place so um that's fun do
you like Gatorade when I'm wildly hung
over absolutely
1,000% um it's a very easy to swallow
liquid um I love your videos thank you
Jonathan I love that you actually have
spent any time watching any of them what
events did you run and track for school
uh I did track in high school I did
indoor and outdoor track indoor and
outdoor track and I did cuz my body is
made up of like 75% legs I did hurdles
high jump long jump and I did a little
bit of PVA and triple jump um and
because we had such a small track team
like I would try and do the 4X one and
try and do the 4x4 and it was just never
good and like the the 400 hurdles and it
just that was not good um but anyway did
I do soccer uh when I was in like fourth
and fifth grade I did soccer cuz every
other girl in my town did soccer cuz
that's what the cool girls did the cool
girls and the cool boys played soccer
and I don't know why that is like I
still don't know why that is and I've
talked to a lot of people and that is
like a stereotype for a lot of suburban
towns is it like cool girls and cool
boys play
soccer I don't know um thought some
birds um they have they have the
superpower that it seems like most
humans want when you're asking someone
what would be the superpower that they'd
most want so that's envious but I also
don't love birds of closeth cuz I just
don't trust them CU they don't know what
they're going to do
but yeah that's it thoughts on dicks I
mean they exist in the world another
movie in the making there's potentially
some stuff in the making that's going to
happen hopefully at some point in the
future so take that to the bank and cash
that thought
in
um chili okay thoughts on
vegans good for you good for you uh I've
actually been trying to eat less meat um
not necessarily consciously just out of
like taste like I I want to eat more
vegetables but good for vegans
um I do want to figure out o if you guys
know any really good vegan mac and
cheese recipes please let me know cuz I
I'm not vegan but I have a lactose issue
so Dairy and cheese are always like the
bummer for me um and I love macaroni and
cheese and I would love to try and make
my own um without totally like
destroying my butthole um so if you guys
have any like awesome recipes that you
have tried that are great please let me
know that would be great uh let's see
hey USA
question if you get so mayry and I did
this um travel show called Hey USA we
did two seasons of it um I I was like
sort of involved in the second season
we've been trying to get a third season
going for like the last two years and
it's really difficult but trust us it's
one of the most favorite projects that
both of us have worked on excuse me
disgusting grow um and if someone would
like to help produce a third season we
are so ready cuz we love traveling with
each other and all of those episodes if
you guys haven't seen them are on
YouTube hey how
convenient um
let's the Vicon Australia I've heard of
it oh I'm going to VidCon Amsterdam are
any of you guys going to be at VidCon
Amsterdam I'll be there Hannah will be
there may will be there and i' I've
never been to Amsterdam before in my
life ever so I'm um really really
excited so if any of you were going
that'd be really cool though I assume
that at this time of day people that
live in Amsterdam are probably sleeping
so that is a moo Point
um but for the rest of you hey there's
some news uh thoughts on Beyonce she's
great and she's got two humans growing
in her stomach isn't that crazy did you
guys like her performance at the Grammys
I thought it was very ethereal very cool
very spiritual um and a much different
Tempo uh but my favorite pregnant
Beyonce performance of all time and just
my favorite Beyonce performance of all
time is level on top where she announced
that she was pregnant for the first time
to Jay-Z oh go back I highly encourage
you go back and watch that performance o
it'll get you in all the spots all the
spots it's emotional um and it's it's
really
good your videos are the highlight of my
day that's awesome thank you for
watching the videos that's really cool
have I seen RuPaul's Drag Ray season 9
trailer no I haven't seen it yet is it
available oh no oh no okay so I have a
to-do list that I'm setting up
after after this okay
um okay I
sorry I'm trying
to
hi hi Grace hi um Jane the Virgin yeah I
haven't watched that show I heard about
it I got my hot dog tea today that's
awesome yeah a bunch of you that ordered
this um hot dog tea uh pocket t-shirt
that I was selling through represent a
couple weeks ago finally got it which is
so exciting so cool you guys all look
good in them um tag me in the photos
that you post of yourself in the hot dog
te cuz I've been going through Instagram
and Twitter and liking all of them fave
SNL sketch when Melissa McCarthy played
Spicer the other weekend I've watched it
like 10 times I've cried every time it's
so funny her picking up the podium and
trying to Ram journalists with it is so
funny to me highly recommend thoughts on
pentatonics I mean they're just the
coolest most talented people like and
they're so humble and sweet and they're
just so good they're just so good um
sorry I get really emotional about them
uh which is they're just so good they're
just so good fave Snapchat filter oh
what's my favorite Snapchat filter oo
what is my favorite Snapchat filter
um uh I I I like I like the ones that
don't have music in the background any
of them that don't have music in the
background cuz the music in the
background you're very limited you can't
make commentary because you can't hear
the audio so I wish that if the music
filters I wish if they want to continue
to create filters with music in the
background that when you start talking
it like lowers the music automatically
cuz like i' I have like many like
perfect jokes of mine just my classic
perfect jokes have been drown out by
Snapchat music um I I like the one now I
just posted that's got like the giant
smile like the chesher cat smile I think
that was fun which is cool have I ever
given blood yes I have given blood oh
and it it was it was I did it for a
video I hate needles I'd never given
blood before when I was in um that Ford
Fiesta program where I had a Ford Fiesta
I I donated blood to the Red Cross and
it was I oh that was um that was an
experience I made it through recommend
that everyone else does it it's not the
worst I didn't die but it really got me
good and was uh oof I was suppressing
Mania panic attack for like 20 minutes
which was fun super cute do you like
koalas I like them in photos I've never
seen one in person other than I guess at
the zoo when I was younger maybe but I
have a feeling now if I were to like as
an adult I realized that I'm really
afraid of
animals which is fun to notice about
yourself um I mean like certain animals
so I think if I held a koala I'd be like
cuz they they have claws like they like
for real claws um and so I think they'd
be cute but I'd be also very very tense
I'm drunk and mad at my boyfriend okay
cool TGF you get it hi from New Jersey
hello how's New Jersey doing is it okay
I hope so what's Goose's outfit of the
day um goose is wearing a t-shirt that I
made her for Valentine's Day it's got a
heart on the back it looks like one of
those candy uh hearts and it says I'm
needy on it um it was on my Snapchat a
little while ago um and I made that I
printed it out and I ironed it on to the
back of her shirt some say I could have
got a lot of other actual work done that
I should have gotten done in the time
that I made that shirt but I say hey you
you have to make time for
art right do I eat fish yes I do eat
fish and I really like fish someone said
I'm bleeding help me help someone helps
that person that's bleeding um
okay
um oh my gosh sorry trying to read this
and does Goose have an Instagram no I
don't have an Instagram for her cuz I
can barely maintain my own Instagram let
alone like something that doesn't speak
words Instagram um there's a spider on
my wall where don't do this don't do
this don't play this game with me don't
you do this no no no cuz I do not like
spiders and there are usually many in my
house that I've been um dealing with
have I been to St Louis yes I've sat
under the arch it was an arch it was
made of metal I saw it and then I
left hi from Montana hello human that
lives in Montana Montana seems pretty
beautiful I've never been there before
thoughts on sorted food those guys are
the best if you haven't watched sorted
food on YouTube you're really missing
out they're British boys that cook and
are funny and they're friends and
they're sweet and just so lovely and
they really know their way around the
kitchen so go check them
out hi from Houston hi from Virginia
come to London yes all of these I Las
Vegas Colorado India Alberta Taylor
Swift I've heard of all of those
countries they sound great um show us
the plant behind me oh that this is not
a plant this is fake
heyy like my personality just kidding um
this is eucalyptus fake eucalyptus I
bought from Michael's craft
store because I yeah what's real
nothing's real
um oh someone's saying there's a spider
in the
back someone wait someone said there's a
spider in the back corner of my room
right up right up there I'm G to
investigate hold on hold on hold on
everyone be cool everyone calm
down okay Goose it's fine everything's
fine it's fine it's not a spider it's
just a moth it's just a very tired moth
don't worry it's not a spider everyone
calm down it's just a very sleepy moth
so let's just let it be let it be
someone says prank call mry do you know
that I can't do that cuz she has my
phone
number um also I hate I'm so bad at
pranks I hate pranking them uh I hate
just pranks in general um what is love o
easy question to answer on a Friday
afternoon um ask your
parents they they made you because of
love so ask them what that how what how
that happened
um do you know what Korean dramas are
are um I I know the genre Korean drama
but I I don't know any specific Korean
dramas people have sent me a gif of a
woman slapping a man with a handful of
spaghetti that I believe is from a
Korean drama but I'm not totally sure if
you guys know that gif let me know where
that's actually from um would you ever
come to
Chile
Chili's or chili uh I would go to both
hi from Trinidad hello from Trinidad
that that I love that the Trinidad and
Tobago I don't I'm just saying words now
I'm sorry guys sorry change of the
Rhythm question mark oh Kitty Perry's
new song you guys like it I think it's
good I got to get myself into it more
because I've just been on a rhythm of
listening to like the same 10 songs over
and over and over so I got to allow
myself to enjoy it hi from Canada hi
Canada hi from Asheville hey hey Nova
Scotia Argentina Arizona socks help me
all right I mean tell me how you really
feel about Arizona um who's my dream not
to deep guest uh not too deep as my
podcast if any of you don't know I have
a podcast um that I've been doing for
the last three years we've had really
amazing guests on recently and who would
be my dream not to deep guest um
honestly I I mean like
h i I think I want to talk to James
Cordon like I I've worked I've done
videos with him but it's always been
like this really quick thing and he's
always super busy that I would love to
like just have an hour of his time where
he feels
totally um like in a safe space to like
talk casually with me would be super
cool I think maybe I just want to talk
offline with James Gordon about the
business and have like ask him advice on
everything um so yeah that would be cool
o Betty White on not too deep o I think
I'd be so nerous nervous I think I would
be so nervous to have her on cuz I think
she'd be too good and I would embarrass
myself um who's my favorite Queen from
Rupal from drag race I think someone
said I love I mean it's really hard um
Alyssa Edwards is so hilarious to me and
the gifs of Alyssa Edwards and her
facial expressions are so great Bob the
drag queen is so funny and so good and I
just love that he I mean you guys know
me my aesthetic is like makeshift
homemade well-intentioned mess and I
think Bob the drag queen brings that
element into the drag World which I like
a lot that like it's really really funny
on like an intentionally funny level and
then it's also like purposely kind of
sloppy which I really like um DIY dog
clothes oh do you guys um yeah I've
always thought about diying dog clothes
but my friend Joselyn Hugh
who has a YouTube channel uh called DIY
Dam it she has a whole video about how
you can take old t-shirts um of your own
and cut them down and make dog clothing
out of it and it's so funny her dogs
actually her dog and her friend's dog
actually make the t-shirts in the video
so um go to DIY Dam it.com or
youtube.com/ DIY damit and there's a
whole video on how you can make dog
clothes from Old t-shirts that you have
which is hey I mean
upcycle
uh
um no filter show soon maybe I mean you
guys will know as soon as we know for
doing no filter shows but will say
Hannah M and I have talked about wanting
to do some more no filter shows in the
future um because I think we go in those
Peaks and valleys of missing performing
live so we'll see someone said you look
nice that's kind of you I'm trying real
hard to look like I'm holding
on oh get Dan and fill not too deep yeah
I would love to have Dan and fill and
not too deep I feel
like I feel like I know them so my
laundry is spinning so if you hear a
weird noise that's what's happening also
the other weird noise is just rain and
then the other weird noise is like me
just talking um I would love to have Dan
and Phil on not too deep for some weird
reason I just I think I've already had
them on not too deep which isn't true um
and they're super busy and we're never
in the
same physical place for enough time time
to like schedule something like that but
I would love that I think they'd be so
fun um so yeah anyway let's
see Liza Koshi oh not too deep yeah I
mean she's like on the top list of
people that I want on we're trying we're
trying we're working on it I also just
want to hang out with her I think she's
so cool and so funny and so sweet um so
working on all levels of the LI of Koshi
oh Neil to Grass Tyson if I got Neil to
Grass Tyson on not too deep I think I'd
be too nervous I took a photo of him I
never ever like go up to people and like
just say can I take a photo and I I did
to him and I was so I just felt so
embarrassed that I did that even though
so many other people were doing I just
felt so embarrassed cuz I I I he's just
a nice guy he's a real nice guy oh I'll
get Beyonce on not too deep that's an
easy get super easy get I'll just hide
out at the hospital hit until she gives
birth to those babies and I know she's
not going anywhere for a little bit so
we'll just start rolling into the
recording uh Rosen Rosie yeah that
there's a you guys are pointing out a
lot of great people that I all because I
know them assume that they've already
been on the podcast but they actually
haven't so um yeah I I these are all
great suggestions guys thank you for
your suggestions I love
them um are you a milk first or seral
cereal first kind of person I'm
definitely cereal first why would you
put milk first if you don't know how
much
cereal I don't that's chicken or egg I
don't know um how are Zay and Heath oh
we had Zay and Heath on the podcast
recently and they were so funny I got to
maybe like three of the questions that I
wanted to ask them in the first half of
the podcast because they just have so
many Amazing Stories and they're just so
sweet and so funny so I think you guys
will really really like that episode
um when it comes out another movie
someone says exclamation point yeah um
there's some movie stuff Brewing some
Brewing
um show us the haunted bathroom
Noah let me have my bathroom for myself
um dance someone says please give me a
21st birthday shout out happy 21st
birthday yeah don't hurt yourself too
much
um who is my hero who is my hero oh I
don't
know um I have a lot of inspirational
people around me oh what def what
defines a hero what defines a hero
people someone that saves you someone
that saves other people what's the
difference between like someone that is
your inspiration and someone that is
your hero hero by definition is someone
that saves you
right the moth is still in the corner
you guys the moth hasn't moved the moth
might be be
um completely paralyzed I don't know but
the moth is okay don't worry um someone
said how are Scotty and tody on the
podcast they were also super excellent
super funny really really sweet they're
both great episodes I mean I would love
to have all four of them on the podcast
at once Heath Zain Scott and TOD but I I
I think that would be a lot to handle
all at once and I don't know if i' be
able to handle it um but both episodes
are really really fun so I'm excited for
you guys to listen to
them um someone said watch
out for Goose goose got a
bed there she is oh land shark no she's
just going to a she's going up on the
other spot in the house that she goes
and sleeps on but she takes her time
like she's not doing that I won't
pretend they don't see her I won't
pretend they don't see what she's doing
don't
worry
no none of us are looking at you none of
us are looking at
you oh we scared her off we scared her
off I
[Music]
think she chose the other bed she chose
the other bed oh yeah also yeah I'm
listening to the Britney Spears Pandora
station which I highly recommend if
anyone needs recommendations on a
Pandora station it's um really good uh
you should have Kevin Pereira on the
podcast I have had Kevin Pereira on the
podcast if you go back into the archive
of SoundCloud there's a whole episode
with Kevin Pereira and I did his podcast
we like double dipped on podcast that
day so you should check that out cuz
it's already happened Michigan loves me
state of
Michigan what
hi how to make friends in college uh put
yourself out there find people with
like-minded interests and don't settle
for the first people you meet
necessarily unless they're awesome so
yeah that's cool
um oh my laundry's done
hooray what should I drink tonight
someone wants to know I'm assuming you
mean alcoholic
beverage uh my go-to is a vakka soda
because it's just the least amount of
like sugar um so it gives you the um
least amount of Hangover in my opinion
but also I could just be like really
good at convincing myself of that um so
you drink what you like I don't know
what kind of liquor you like everyone's
got different preferences and different
tastes so you do you boo that so natural
rolled off my
tongue excuse me disgusting sorry uh
Margarita cool all right do you love me
I mean I appreciate that you exist
someone said poop okay tips for skin
care um tips for skin care oh excuse me
disgusting I'm so sorry I'm drinking a
diet coke nons spawn I'm drinking a soda
beverage with caffeinated properties
that also has a low amount of sugar
quality um here's a tip for skincare if
you're a lady on my nightstands I have
um makeup wipes in both nightstands so
even I come home um and I'm drunk or
really tired or whatever it is I have no
excuse not to take my makeup off before
I fall asleep because it's just directly
next to me and then I have trash cans
underneath so I can throw away my makeup
wipes so um I think that's a a
beneficial thing to do also I if you
want to like kind of like shame yourself
into like washing your face before you
go to sleep I highly recommend getting
white pillowcases because when you wake
up in the morning and you see your
makeup smeared all over those white
pillowcases you will absolutely consider
washing your face the next time that you
go to sleep um cuz you can't have anyone
sleep over because your pillows and your
whole bed looks like a a pile of garbage
um so that helps like really force you
into seeing how much of a dirt bag you
actually are so it's
fun oh see I think Goose has to go to
the bathroom but she's afraid to use her
dog door and go outside cuz it's so wet
outside so I might go deal with that and
help her out in a second um so I think
I'm going to we've been live streaming
for like 38 minutes this was really fun
you guys I didn't have any plans
necessarily for this but I just couldn't
figure out a clever enough video that I
wanted to shoot this afternoon so I
appreciate you
guys like bearing with me and being here
but I also want to incorporate more live
streams now that I know the process of
doing them that's not to say that I will
immediately forget the process of doing
them next time so
um oh my God she might be going up to
our secret spot I W pretend that you're
not staring directly at my dog's botle
just pretend just
pretend
she's just sniffing the pillow like no
one is looking at
her no big
deal no big deal we're not looking at
you we're not looking at you no one's
looking at
you oh she's distracted anyway
um hi you sitting cuz you don't want to
go outside okay I'm going to go help her
go outside so she can use a restroom
thank you guys so much for hanging out
with me today I want to do more live
streams so let me know um your thoughts
on that and if there's a particular day
of the week or time that you would
prefer over other days of the week and
other time and that's it all right
thanks guys this is really fun I'll see
you guys um when I see you and don't
forget to like go watch all the videos
on this channel go listen to not too
deep it's on Soundcloud and iTunes
soundcloud.com notto deep withg Grace
and then just look up not too deep on
podcast on iTunes and you can watch the
full episodes on fulls screen app if you
go to fullscreen.com you can download it
it's all it's all just really fun this
you I don't I don't need to plug this is
not about plugging all right have a
great weekend you guys tjf thanks again
for hanging out I see you want to see
you
goodbye